what advice do you have for a
screenwriter when they sit down to start
writing a screenplay what are some
things they should have already done
before they type that first page whether
it's outlining they should have beside
them a list of the 100 most recent
screenplays that they have read the
published ones the successful ones okay
I'll give you a break make it 50 you are
not ready to write until you are very
well-read and well-versed in the
literature you are proposing to create
and in this in this place its
screenwriting
I would say systematize your
organization the first thing you have to
do see a really bad habit that most
screenwriters have is they got a great
idea and they're cooking and they just
start writing screenplay I'm writing
screenplay pages oh boy and it's fun but
it's going nowhere
ultimately without a plan and a very
well thought out the hard work is in the
outline and it has to be a very complete
outline and you have to have confidence
that all story problems have been
addressed so the first thing you have to
do is the dirty work the outline write
yourself I would say here real goal
sequences because I happen to think it
and I happen to know that it works but
however you know beat sheet however they
do it have a very complete outline and
then good bloody luck it's it's it's a
lot of work and then I would also say
yeah you write it on a little piece of
paper and tape it above your desk write
badly with pride
no no writer's block none just write
badly with bride write a piece of piece
of junk you know if you haven't have you
just sitting there staring at the wall
for an hour okay what would you write if
you were just really writing trash
really writing garbage go for it
because you never know when the real
idea is the depth of what you are doing
will be sparked you just don't know you
don't know and there's so many things
you have the tone yeah I'm working I'm
beginning to have some fun at this stage
of things I have you know some some
original screenplays of course as it
turns out that never sold and yeah
frequently what happens is the stuff you
like the most that's the stuff that
doesn't sell and there are three or four
of them that I'm I want to turn into in
turn into novels before my clock and
race have been run and I started on one
there's some months back and I've been
working a month and a half now on the
first five pages every day I do it's
it's yeah I've kind of fell into it but
it's what artists having way did every
day he started at page one and that's
what I have to do you know by
instruction being instructed by him but
also by a nature every day I started
page one you can do that for the first
40 or 50 pages you reach a point you
know it doesn't work anymore but what
you do by that what you gain by that is
do not be in a hurry to zoom onward you
because those first 5 to 10 pages are
the most important pages in the holes
and the whole thing in a novel in a
screenplay you either convince your
audience it's worth to come along or
reader it's it's worth their time to
come along for this journey with you or
not that you II either they trust you by
then or they don't so in the search for
tone rhythm the use of language and
character
it's amazing spending five pages with
with your central character in this case
what you can learn about that character
and doing the same five pages over and
over and over and over and over you'll
learn a heck of a lot about your hero
this is invaluable as you move forward
so I would say also don't rush
you